اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم
الحكومه الاسرائيليه تصدق على اختصار
مراحل اجراءات البناء الاستيطاني وتمنح
وزير الماليه رئيس حزب الصهيونيه المتطرف
صلاحيات التصديق على الاجراءات والخارجيه
الفلسطينيه تصف القرار بانه تصعيد خطير
لاستكمال ضم الضفه في اول زياره
لدبلوماسيه امريكي رفيع المستوى منذ خمس
سنوات لينك يجري مباحثات مع المسؤولين في
الصين بشان ملفات عده ابرزها تايوان
والنفوذ العسكري الصيني والمنافسه
الاقتصاديه ومسؤول امريكي يقول ان الهدف
من الزياره اعاده انشاء قنوات الاتصال بين
واشنطن وبيجين هدوء حجري يخيم على السودان
بعد دخول هدنه جديده حيزه تنفيذ لمده
ثلاثه ايام برعايه سعوديه امريكيه الجيش
يتواعد بالرد على اي خرق وقوات الدعم
السريع تعلن التزامها بعدم عرقله وصول
المساعدات
بسبب تلاش الامال في العثور على ناجينا
جدد وسائل اعلام يونانيه تقول ان عمليات
البحث عن ناجين ومفقودين من غرق سفينه
لطالب اللجوء قد تتوقف اليوم
ومحامون يونانيون يعلنون نيتهم رفع دعوى
قضائيه ضد اداره خفر سواحل بلادهم بتهمه
التقصير
الى اللقاء